vous lisez vous y étiez et il ya une
info folle il paraît qu'ils avaient joey
starr à l'aéroport ce jour là c'est pas
une toile
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des minutes et
tout au fond en fait ah oui là il n'a
rien vu en fait rien vu ba ouais non
plus à part avoir été violent envers
gilles verdez tu vois pas non plus et
non mais c est qu il était là oui toi
t'as paniquer ben moi je suis arrivé
plus tôt vers la fin ouais et en fait ma
copine est arrivé là et vu qu'il y avait
crise et qu'on est arrivé vers vers
notre porte
on a vu booba au loin et là on a vu des
altercations que ça bouge et partout on
s'est dit c'est bizarre en plus yakari
cette ville est la plus directe un
rapprochement fait et après on a vu il y
avait des flaques de vin par terre il y
avait des gouttes de sang par terre
alors ils sont arrivés ils sont arrivés
tout à l'heure au tribunal on va voir
l'arrivée de boubacar sy aujourd'hui il
regarde voilà donc là ils sont arrivés
tout à l'heure voilà donc tout le monde
en parle moi ce qui me rend fou c'est
que bfm tv tf1 où ça en boucle par tous
c'est ça qui est incroyable voilà et on
a notre correspondant qui est là bas
salut ça mais ça va ça mais ça lui sert
il ça va bien alors et alors qu'est ce
qui se passe ça va super super et
comment ils sont arrivés dans quel état
ils étaient tous les deux s'étaient
tendues il veut et souriez délais et les
malins où il était attendu
c'est énorme
j'ai l'impression qu'il est à leur
écoute et cyril ils sont arrivés aux
alentours de 13 heures ici au tribunal
de créteil
ils sont arrivés assez détendu a
accompagné de tous leurs avocats
respectifs
quand ils sont entrés à l'intérieur du
du tribunal et bien ils sont passés par
une entrée différente de celle où les
fans les attendaient il y en avait
beaucoup de fans qui les attendait j'ai
pu m'entretenir un peu avec eux ils me
disaient voilà c'était l'occasion pour
eux et bien de rencontrer pour de vrai
et bien ce ces deux rappeurs qui
pour certains depuis plusieurs années
alors on joue pas l'audience continue
juste derrière moi à l'intérieur de
cette salle d'audience du tribunal de
créteil
alors on noie on aura des nouvelles on
reste il se passe quelque chose tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que ce qui avait posé
aussi ce jour là si vous avez vu pendant
la bagarre c'est que pendant la bagarre
il ya un jeune homme qui est passé et
qui en a profité pour prendre un parfum
regarde mais j'ai un retour sous le choc
le seul de l'année chaque délit le choc
de la dalle est alors vous qui l'êtes
pas du tout dans le juste un rapport à
ça ce matin dans quand même le parisien
fait un gros titre en disant qu'ils
avaient de la tapenade volé dans son
volet de la taper la balle
y a pas un gars qui fait aux petites
heures du jour n'avait eu parisien quand
même il ya eu des dommages collatéraux
vous faire attention alors oui oui alors
qu'il peut revenir à ce qu'a dit théo
parce que quand même on le laisse dire
n'importe quoi c'est pas parce qu'on est
jeune voudrait dire des conneries
monsieur bah non mais vous avez dit que
vous n'étiez pas choqué que vous étiez
choqué par le traitement qu'on est dur à
l'aller gens qui se battent dans un
aéroport qui se blesse comme ça thierry
ce je vous le rappelle 10 en prison pour
ça vous trouvez ça normal vous comprends
que les images choc c'est pas là où je
veux en venir le jour où je veux en
venir c'est le rap
les gens font généralité booba vient
toujours à ça on est obligées de faire
l'amalgamme excusez moi un bon mari vous
êtes journaliste gilles verdez oui
plusieurs arrêtés par des amalgames